internet is the collection of
several computers
I never used the internet
[Music]
in
he lies
it stops without harassing them
information I'm going to look into
internet the balloon
[Music]
but
com
well it's power 10 15 miles
we missed each other says that holds disadvantage
is human education and a pile of
skills and elements that pull
artistic and geographical location and
the historical period
so what do you want
search science science
see but holds vaudois middle I
badly to the researchers I would take without
[Music]
to play
all
[Music]
on the shelves
I saw the rigid patterns and I am
out of the cinema on all that and I tried
to thwart and I support 18 it's me who
was first also roll the
ancient times 10 at home there we do not
did not expect to see in this genre
of help appears in our school in
our schools and this is the only role
title in other departments
and if they do not wait at all
place but already with wikipedia us
let's go a lot of looking for things
you do not have to wear a bag of
books or prepare moleson this is a
opening of the era of near sour
because the image of the school is
really big universal
[Music]
quickly no more
that never
the
you
or not
the images and sounds
[Applause]
[Music]
Well, yes, yes